alors on plonge les terrasses dans l'eau
et on attend qui viennent à la surface
vous voyez tout un monde à la surface
tranquillement
c'est vraiment étonnant ça ressemble à
rien de ce qu'on connaît vraiment
c'est quoi pour les Italiens le Taral
c'est du pain c'est une grignotine
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est pas du pain
une collation
tantôt on va faire les tout-petits qu'on
va prendre à l'apéro avec des olives un
peu de charcuterie tout ça c'est un bon
dépanneur moi j'en fais que je cherche
souvent pendant brunch le matin puis on
en a qui sont plus sucrés pour les
collations des enfants pour n'importe
quelle heure de la journée ils sont
petits ou plus gros surtout rond mais
parfois allongé on dit que chaque région
a sa recette partons découvrir les
Taralis
écoutez il y a tellement de sortes de
talent les taralines et dans toute
l'Italie mais je pense que à la base
littérales ça vient de la région des
pôles et les Abruzzes l'Italie centrale
ça vient pas tout en Italie ce Nord tout
le monde fait différents
avec de l'huile d'olive
les fenouil les joutes de peut-être
poivre Napoli c'était connu avec
une façon différente mais c'est fait
avec
trois chefs natifs de région différentes
de l'Italie et de nombreuses versions de
ta rally dans leur bagages
je suis la recette mais finalement
c'était crème italien puis je comprends
pas mais vous vous la connaissez par
Carla connais par cœur parce que les
recettes que je vous fais aujourd'hui ce
sont des recettes que que je fais depuis
toujours moi j'ai la recette de ma mère
j'ai encore son petit litre que mon père
écrivait et puis je suis sûr que ma mère
dictée et ça date quand même de
longtemps on dirait un petit Bégon oui
mais c'est ça c'est que
Tarani taraline c'est la même chose les
recettes que je fais ce sont surtout de
l'Italie centrale ma région natale les
Abruzzes
[Musique]
j'ai Arte Farina Sandro prépare la
recette des Pouilles
c'est pas les premiers que vous faites
facile mais la pâte c'est élastique
l'important c'est avoir toujours la même
grandeur cela vous allez avoir des cuir
des parcs
c'est quoi les ingrédients
c'est aussi le vin blanc le vin blanc
qui va donner un petit pot de acidité à
la fin
lui prépare ses taralli dans un petit
local de Montréal Nord avec l'aide de
son fils
qui l'a commencé et ça sa partie de la
moi je vais la faire simple mais la
bonne manière de le faire pour Nicolas
et bien sûr celle de sa mère il a
conservé sa recette mais l'adapter pour
répondre aux exigences des épiceries
italiennes qu'il fournit
ailleurs au Québec vous passez des temps
on dit que c'est souvent un cadeau qu'on
donne quand on est reçu chez les gens
c'est vrai ça se donne bien ce message
dans un petit sac c'est rendu mon
heureux oui chemin moi je le fais dans
tout cas notre petite deuxième recette
on va faire des talents les ovins avec
ajout de graines d'anis l'huile ça fait
l'huile végétale mais pour une italienne
c'est de l'huile d'olive
moi je les aime torsadés on tourne c'est
de toute beauté de vous voir travaux
et oui ça peut être la collation des
enfants pour terminer Maria prépare des
petites à lignes sans œufs et des tartes
j'ai commencé par l'apéro mais le goût
du vin avec cuit légèrement sucré que
c'est bon ça vous le trempez dans le
café ou vous pouvez vous pouvez chacun
sa façon mais c'est pas la tradition de
le tremper je pensais que les Italiens
non pour chaque fête tous les moyens
sont bons pour s'amuser et puis pour
recevoir et pour voir les voisins et la
famille etc etc je trouve que mes
ancêtres savaient faire beaucoup avec
peu
farine de l'huile du vin puis je
l'abondance qu'on a sur la table merci
de partager ça avec nous ça me fait
plaisir
[Musique]